c'est ta dernière chanson ça c'est ma
dernière non tu perds mais je me permets
de te dire tu as oublié
oui enfin j'ai pensé que c'était pas la
peine qu'on sentait que ça se passait au
téléphone c'est sûr mais moi je le
prends pas ce que je vais te dire j'ai
l'impression que oui c'est pas bien
comprendre j'ai des problèmes tous et
pourtant je sais ce qu'il faut faire je
sais comment sont les femmes c'est la
douceur de la biche l'est les griffes du
félin enfin tous fermés mais c'est ça
les femmes non mais oui peut-être mais
je lui mais non ils font les il faut les
prendre beaucoup plus réaliste tu vois
et puis un peu actor studio c'est à dire
je t attends bouge pas tu restes là à
l'eau et pense attend sa réponse
s'interroge pas là ça y est allo chérie
je t'épouserais jamais parce que je
t'aime trop j'espère respect oui chérie
olala faudrait tellement que tu viennes
habiter chez moi ou juste à côté parce
que j'aime bien mes aises à l'eau chérie
chéri je voudrais qu'on parte tous les
deux tout seul tous les deux tout seul
avec mon père ma mère l'est du pont la
caravane tout on irait au bord de la
méditerranée
il aurait la belle-mère bleus devant
nous ma belle-mère en noir derrière tu
m'entends ferry et que je caresserait
doucement tout doucement notre berger
allemand oui
chérie avec moi tu auras tout ce que tu
voudras tout tu pourra garder les bijoux
de taner la voiture de ton père tout tu
me feras ton salaire à la fin du mois
cherry et puis le soir tous les deux
devant la cheminée on se regardera et
puis tu me nettoiera les verres de
contact et plus tard encore beaucoup
plus tard chéri quand le temps aura
marqué ton si doux visage et bien à ce
moment-là chérie si je suis encore
libres je déposerai maintenant nous
allons véronique sanson mais alors après
ghsr à laquelle pour voir si sa marge
est humain
nous